[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Diễn giả 1: Làm cách nào để chúng tôi tích hợp các trường hợp thử nghiệm Jasmine với codepen?
>> Brian Holt: Câu hỏi hay.
Hãy để tôi chỉ cho bạn một cách ngắn gọn vì nó nằm ngoài phạm vi của lớp học nhưng
nếu bạn nhấp vào codepen, sau đó bạn nhấp vào Cài đặt và bạn nhấp vào JavaScript.
Lưu ý rằng tôi chỉ bao gồm một loạt các tệp Jasmine và
Tôi chỉ lấy đó ra khỏi bài đăng trên blog của ai đó.
Trên thực tế, bạn có thể chỉ cần tìm kiếm một cành hoa Nhài và nó sẽ ở trên đó.
Cũng có một tệp CSS,
nhưng nó chỉ là một loạt các liên kết bên ngoài bao gồm JavaScript.
>> Brian Holt: Được rồi, hãy cùng nhau giải quyết vấn đề này.
Vì vậy, ở đây chúng tôi sẽ đặt mã của chúng tôi.
Có ghi chú của tôi ở đây, và
Tôi sẽ tạo một hàm được gọi là giai thừa, và nó sẽ nhận một (n).
Một điều thú vị khác cần lưu ý về CodePen, là nếu bạn thấy màu đỏ này
dấu chấm than ở đây, có nghĩa là nó không biên dịch.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn nhấp vào đó, nó sẽ bắt đầu hét vào mặt bạn
nó sẽ cho bạn biết nó đang gặp vấn đề ở đâu trong trường hợp cụ thể này, chúng tôi không
có dấu ngoặc nhọn nên nó là người đàn ông nhưng vì chúng ta đặt một dấu ngoặc nhọn mà nó biến mất.
Điều đáng nói khác là tôi đã bật Babel.
Vì vậy, một lần nữa đến đây vào Cài đặt xem JavaScript mọi thứ đang được chạy
thông qua Babel để bạn có thể thoải mái sử dụng tất cả ES6 ngoại trừ máy phát điện.
Chúng tôi không sử dụng máy phát điện và điều đó không sao, nhưng
chỉ nói rằng codepen có vấn đề với máy phát điện nên thậm chí không thử.
Được rồi, dòng đầu tiên của đệ quy của chúng ta,
điều đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ làm là gì?
Trường hợp cơ sở, phải không?
Vì vậy, nếu (n <2),
thì chúng ta sẽ trả về 1,
khá đơn giản, được không?
Và bây giờ giai thừa là gì?
Chà, đó là giai thừa n * của (n- 1).
>> Brian Holt: Đó là nó và nếu bạn nhìn xuống đây,
bạn nhận thấy rằng bài kiểm tra của chúng tôi hiện đang vượt qua.
>> Brian Holt: Một lần nữa để chứng minh ở đây nó là giai thừa nếu bạn
suy nghĩ về Bất kể con số là bất cứ điều gì
giai thừa của số trừ một, phải không?
Và đó thực sự là những gì chúng ta đang diễn đạt thành mã, phải không?
Đó là giai thừa n lần của (n- 1).
Vì vậy, đó là thứ thực sự có thể giúp bạn, chỉ cần lý do cho phép
về những gì đang xảy ra.
Điều này hữu ích cho tôi và nó gây nhầm lẫn cho những người khác.
Một số tôi sẽ nói rõ nó và nếu nó khiến bạn bối rối hơn, hãy vứt nó đi.
Bạn có thể nghĩ về phần thân của hàm
của một hàm đệ quy giống như phần bên trong của vòng lặp, phải không?
Đó là một bản tóm tắt rất rò rỉ không đi quá xa với điều đó
chỉ cần nghĩ về điều đó, đó là mã được chạy đi chạy lại nhiều lần.
Chỉ cần bạn thực hiện một vòng lặp for, bất kể mã nào ở giữa vòng lặp for
vòng lặp đó là những gì được chạy đi chạy lại nhiều lần.
Đây là cùng một khái niệm chung.
Đây là mã sẽ được chạy nhiều lần.
Có lẽ điều đó giúp bạn có thể không có bất kỳ câu hỏi nào?
Vì vậy, hãy đóng nó lại.
Rời khỏi trang này, rời khỏi trang đó.
Và một lần nữa, tất cả các câu trả lời đều có ở đây, vì vậy nếu bạn đang đấu tranh hoặc
bạn muốn quay lại sau và xem xét nó, tất cả các câu trả lời mà tôi đang đưa ra ở đây,
họ cũng có chúng ngay tại đây.
>> Brian Holt: Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi cũng đã sửa tất cả.
Một trong số họ đã sai.
Đúng vậy.